a new study released by the bureau
reclamation projects another drop in
lake mead's
water level the report says it is now at
1085
feet but it could go down below 1070
feet
that would trigger a water shortage
declaration
experts say the lack of snow in the
colorado rockies is the main reason for
that
bronson mack with the las vegas valley
water district says by 2022
we could be under that water shortage
declaration
as far as further restrictions go we're
going to have to see there is certainly
the potential that
we could tweak a couple of our
conservation programs or the couple of
the conservation rules
just to ensure that everybody is
following those rules and we're
continuing to save water so
i don't want to say that there won't be
anything else to come because there
certainly is the potential for that
last week snowpack was about 28 below
average and like denise just we just
talked about
it has to snow on the western part of
the rockies a lot of snow there
to fill lake b denise